La Llorona, known as the “The Weeping”
or “Wailing Woman” was likely born in
the 1650s.
We know this because she appears to be in
her twenties when she is married with children
in 1673.
La Llorona was alive so long ago that the
best known record of her mostly comes from
the folklore surrounding her.
While the stories vary, depending on the source,
a few constants overlap.
When La Llorona was young, she had a different
name.
In some retellings, it’s Maria but in a
well known play written in 1917, it’s Luisa.
In many iterations of the story, she was born
into poverty but as she grew up she became
incredibly beautiful.
So much so, that she drew the attention of
a wealthy ranchero.
He married her and they had two boys.
Unfortunately these children would not live
for very long, as she gave them live and she
took it away, thus beginning the curse of
La Llorona.
To find out what drove this young mother to
commit this act, how she became known as the
weeping woman, and how her curse endangered
generations of children, stick around to the
end of this video.
This video is sponsored by Audible.
(metal music)
Welcome to Horror History – In today’s
lesson, I’ll be covering the life, and afterlife,
of one of Mexico and Central America’s most
iconic legends, La Llorona.
There’s not a lot documented about the childhood
of La Llorona, but one thing that is consistent
across the various legends is that she grew
up in poverty, so when a wealthy conquistador
came to her town and pursued her, it makes
sense that this would be a very big deal to
her.
According to History Today, there was initially
a shortage of Spanish women in what the Spanish
dubbed as “New Spain”, the region that is
now referred to as “Spring Break”.
This meant that unions between indigenous
women and Spanish men were quite common.
However many of these unions didn’t last
very long.
To get a better understanding, we’ll need
to take it back to Mexico and parts of Central
America during the 1600s where this iteration
of the legend originates.
(spanish guitar music)
“The fates of indigenous and mestiza women
who married Spaniards were mixed.
Some enjoyed stability and enhanced status.
But more often than not, they were cast aside
after a few years for younger women or, more
often, a Spanish wife.
More alarmingly, their children were sometimes
taken away, a practice that derived from the
Spanish tradition of relieving so-called ‘wayward’
women of their children.”
This left many women during this time left
to feel completely helpless – La Llorona
is kind of an embodiment of the collective
pain and anger of women from this time, that
got turned into legend.
It’s something that’s come up a lot in
Horror History, from Godzilla being a metaphor
for nuclear fallout to The Demogorgon being
a manifestation of fears of communism.
I think we need a term for this so I’ll
call it…
Cultural Legendizing.
That sounds pretty good.
There are different iterations of La Llorona,
but for the sake of Horror History, we’ll
stick to the lore as told in The Conjuring
universe, more specifically, the 2019 film
The Curse Of La Llorona.
According to the local Priest, Father Perez,
the story goes as follows: La Llorona fell
in love and had two sons with her husband.
The family loved each other, and her sons
demonstrated their care for her by giving
her a necklace:
– “I will wear this forever”.
– I don’t think she knew at the time how literally
true this statement was.
Father Perez explains that she and her family
were happy until one day when she found her
man in the arms of a younger woman.
In a fit of rage, she took away what he deemed
the most valuable, his testicles.
Oh wait, no, it was his children, and she
drowned them in the nearby river.
As soon as her rageblindness cleared and she
realized what she’d done, she weeped and
then took her own life in the same river,
cursing herself to an eternity of trying to
find souls of children to trade for her own.
– Children are told to behave, listen to
their elders, or La Llorona will come and
steal them away.
– It kind of seems like the moral of the story
has been aimed at the wrong people.
The kids are the only people who didn’t
do anything wrong and they suffered the most,
and future generations of children are made
to fear the tale La Llorona, when it should
probably be directed at couples.
For the next one hundred years, La Llorona
continued to haunt the river and other bodies
of water, searching for children to kill.
As the legend of grew, people claimed to hear
a woman crying.
Some followed the sounds to find a woman in
a white gown floating above the water.
If children were the ones to find her, she
was said to be ruthless and they wouldn’t
stand a chance of escaping.
These stories mostly come from Mexico, but
like my friends at the nearby taco truck,
the legend would burrow its way across the
border.
In 1973 the weeping appeared in Los Angeles.
All this time I thought it was La Llorona;
maybe it’s actually L.A. Llorona.
It’s never clearly explained how La Llorona
went from haunting one specific river in Mexico
to becoming an Angelino, we just know she’s
doomed to an eternity of searching rivers
and bodies of water.
There are several rivers, such as the Colorado
River or the Tijuana River, that run from
Mexico into Southern California.
So over the course of a hundred years, she
could have migrated up these channels.
While La Llorona was just a children’s tale
to some, the single mother, Patricia Alvarez
and the recent widow, Anna Garcia, were about
to experience the curse first hand.
I think La Llorona targeted these two women
because they are reminiscent of herself.
Patricia is alone raising her kids and based
on Anna’s questions about if she’s started
drinking again, it is clear that she’s had
a rough life and doesn’t have any support
system.
Anna lost her husband in the line of fire
and while he didn’t choose to leave her,
she was still left in a difficult situation
nonetheless.
Both Patricia and Anna have two children close
in age to La Llorona’s two kids, and both
are hispanic.
La Llorona first targets Patricia and her
two sons, Carlos and Tomas.
Patricia seems to take all the necessary steps
to deter the malicious spirit: a shrine of
candles, boarded up windows, religious iconography,
and a closet transformed into a protective
spirit shelter for her kids.
She may have set this up based on her own
knowledge of the legend of La Llorona, which
she demonstrates a pretty clear understanding
of:
– [Patricia] Your children.
Have they heard her crying?
Have they felt the sting of her tears?
They will.
Soon.
– Or she could have received guidance from Rafael,
a currendaro or healer, who is an expert at
handling La Llorona.
This might explain why Rafael is at the service
for the two boys after they are killed and
why he goes back later to collect a sample
of La Llorona’s tears.
Either way, when Anna arrives and finds that
Patricia has hidden her children away, Patricia
begs Anna for “just one more night”, which
seems to imply that if La Llorona isn’t
able to take the children within a certain
time frame, she moves on.
This could be representative of the nature
by which La Llorona killed her own children.
It happened in a fit of rage and once she
had calmed down, she regretted her choice.
So maybe, if given enough time, she will spare
the children she’s after, just as she likely
would have with her own.
But that's just a theory.
A FILM THEO–
In the Conjerverse, La Llorona does not just
kill children upon first sight.
Her haunting follows a specific process, which
we’ve seen before.
Her curse seems to follow the same rules that
apply to demonic possession, by following
the steps of “infestation,” “oppression”
and then finally, “possession.”
In La Llorona’s case, she isn’t necessarily
trying to possess a person in “take-over-their-body”
the sense that we’re used to seeing, but
she is trying to possess childrens’ souls
in order to try to bring her own children
back to her.
It makes sense that La Llorona’s curse follows
the same rules as demonic possession, just
as Bathsheba did with the Perron family back
in 1971.
Bathsheba is not technically a demon, but
the terror she dishes out follows the same
process.
But La Llorona’s version of infestation,
oppression and possession have unique ways
of manifesting themselves, which creates unique
problems for all those involved.
(IMPACT)
Since I've already told you about Ed and Lorraine
Warren's books that you can listen to exclusively
on Audible, there are also many more reasons
to explore the catalog and sign up.
Audible is the ONLY place you can listen to
The Demonologist, the career biography of
Ed and Lorraine.
It's also the home of The Haunted House Diaries
where you can hear about more unexplainable
details of the farmhouse they investigated
in the original movie.
The Conjuring movies can only show you so much.
If you want to know everything, your ticket
is Audible.
Audible offers an incredible selection of
audiobooks across every genre — including
lots of horror.
You’ll also discover exclusive Audible Originals
from top celebrities, renowned experts, and
exciting new voices in audio.
Members get a free title every month, for
keeps.
Plus, there's a great selection of free podcasts.
If you’re new here, welcome to Audible Book
Club.
This month I'm checking out The Grownup by
Gillian Flynn.
It's a short story by one of my favorite authors;
she wrote Gone Girl and Sharp Objects.
I thought I had read all of her stuff, so
I was excited to find this short story on Audible.
To try out Audible Premium Plus free for 30
days visit audible.com/czsworld
or text czsworld to 500-500.
You'll find that link in the description.
audible.com/czsworld
(dark but also chill music)
La Llorona’s curse follows three specific
steps: First, she burns the children with
her tears, by grabbing their arms and scorching
them.
By doing this, she gains access to them, including
the ability to put them in a trance and lure
them to her.
This aspect of the legend would reflect her
own childrens’ trust in her before she drowned them.
With all of her victims, her method of attack
is drowning in the nearest body of water.
The location of the burn marks left on their
arms also ties back to the legend from the
1600s.
The burns are in a very visible spot, and
from what we can see, most or all of the families
her spirit terrorizes are single mothers.
Children in single-parent households are significantly
more likely to be abused, according to this
study in the National Library of Medicine.
As I mentioned, Patricia was already subject
to welfare checks before La Llorona entered
her life.
If abuse is found during a welfare check,
law enforcement may take away the children
for their safety.
So the very visible burn marks feel like La
Llorona’s revenge, after her children were
unfairly taken away from her; she’s imparting
that same pain onto her victims.
This is exactly what happens to Patricia.
Keeping the boys hidden away in the blessed
closet was her last hope at keeping Carlos
and Tomas safe from La Llorona, but during
her welfare check, Anna takes them out leaving
them completely vulnerable.
As the boys sleep in the foster care institution,
La Llorona makes her next move.
She puts Tomas in a trance and summons him
out of the bedroom.
Carlos wakes up, and seeing his brother just
standing at the edge of the room, runs towards
him, trying to get him to come back to bed,
but it’s too late.
Carlos catches sight of La Llorona in the
mirror, then after her briefly disappearing,
he gazes upon a puddle of water from a leak
in the ceiling, and this happens.
– Carlos...
(WAILING SCREAM)
(Carlos screams)
– She grabs both of them and takes them to the
nearby river to drown them.
Anna is called to the crime scene to identify
the bodies and with no father to watch them,
has no choice but to take her own children
with and lock them in the car.
– Stay in the car, OK?
And please don’t wake up your sister.
– But Chris is a kid, and of course, kids don’t
listen to their parents, especially when they’re
right next to an active crime scene that looks
really cool!
Patricia also shows up and, driven mad with
grief, tries to blame Anna for interfering.
When Anna asks what she’s talking about,
Patricia tells her:
– La Llorona.
– At this point, Patricia essentially becomes
a proxy of La Llorona herself.
She prayed to wicked spirit, asking her to
take Anna’s children in place of her own.
–... and I prayed to her,
to give my children back to me and take yours instead!
– Patricia is now following La Llorona’s ghastly
footsteps, hoping to sacrifice other children
in order to trade their souls for her own.
It’s almost as though the spirit La Llorona
sees Anna’s kids through Patricia, because
Anna’s kids aren’t targetted until Patricia
makes eye contact with Chris as she’s taken
away in a police car.
When Chris ignores his mother’s warning
and gets out of the car to investigate, La
Llorona sobs in a nearby alley, luring Chris
to her sound.
As he checks to see if she’s okay, her head
suddenly snaps in his direction and she lunges
toward him, allowing herself to burn him with
her tears by grabbing his arm and scorching
it.
She’s now attached herself to the family.
She chases him back to the car, where he breaks
the other rule that Anna set for him, not
to wake up his sister, as he begs to be let
back in.
Only he can see La Llorona screeching at him
on the other side of the window, but Chris’s
behavior is still enough to scare her.
In addition to that, Samantha becomes La Llorona’s
next target.
The following day, while Anna is at work,
she’s playing out in the rain with a see
through umbrella.
La Llorona attempts to lure her in, the same
way she did with Chris by crying off in the distance.
However, Sam has more self-preservation and
stops at the fence at the end of their yard,
so La Llorona resorts to other tactics.
She blows Sam’s umbrella into the water,
and when she reaches out to get it, she’s
met with a surprise.
(high-pitched scream)
She too is burned when La Llorona grabs her
arm and scorches it with her tears.
That night, she puts Chris into a heavy trance,
and Anna finds him repeatedly opening and
closing the front door.
She thinks he’s sleepwalking, but he’s
really setting the stage for La Llorona to
blow open the door, granting her access to
the house, which she uses to confront Anna
that same night.
– Get out of my house!
– Mom?
–  [Zac] Anna ushers the kids to come in and sleep
in her bed, while staying up all night on
guard with a baseball bat.
The terror continues the next day.
While Anna is at work, La Llorona lures Chris
into Samantha’s bedroom, knocks him to the
floor with another powerful gust of supernatural
wind, and lunges for him, scaring him away
to the edge of the stairs, which she pushes
him down after appearing in the adjacent room.
He lands on his wrist just before Anna walks
through the door and she completely
overreacts, considering from her point of
view, he was just sitting there with a sprained
wrist.
– CHRIS!
CHRIS!!
– Sure, La Llorona probably could have killed
Chris right then and there if she wanted to,
but she may have been setting Anna up, just
like she did to Patricia, to seem like an
ill equipped mother, as she would know first
hand that having her own children taken away
from her was a pain worse than death.
The ensuing social services visit at Anna’s
home was probably a humiliation very much
akin to La Llorona’s feelings when the conquistador
she married took her boys away to a “better
suited” woman.
Also, La Llorona still needs to burn Anna
with the black tears in order to complete
the curse.
As Samantha is upstairs taking a bath alone,
which seems like kinda not a good idea, given
everything that has happened, La Llorona seizes
the opportunity to attack her and bring Anna
to a place of vulnerability.
Samantha is washing her hair with her eyes
closed when she feels a pair of hands massaging
her scalp.
For a brief moment, La Llorona is tender with
Samantha, just as she likely was with her
own children.
Sam is tricked by the feeling of that motherly
touch.
However, as she leans her head back to rinse,
La Llorona’s decrepit hands pull her under
and pin her there.
Anna and Chris hear the commotion in the bathroom
and run up to save her, just in time.
Anna pulls her out of the tub where she crawls
backwards in petrified fear, almost looking
as though she’s scared of her mother, but
actually gazing on to La Llorona.
This time it’s Anna’s turn to get burned
by The Weeping Woman’s touch, just as she
turns around to see her
By this point, La Llorona has marked each
family member to complete the curse and can
now strike at any moment to kill the children.
Things would be complicated, however, when
Anna goes outside the church to bring in reinforcements.
(impact, but slightly different than the one before)
(morbid music)
Anna and the kids seek out the currendero
Rafael, who reluctantly agrees and implements
him unorthodox methods by having Anna and
kids roll eggs all over everything in the
house.
He calls the ritual La Limpa and says that
it’s meant to detect evil in the house.
The ritual of rolling an egg in its shell
to pick up or ward off evil is a practice
that not only goes way back in Mexican healing
but it is still in practice today.
He cracks one egg in a bowl revealing the
yolk to have turned to a burning black tar,
and the other eggs explode, gushing the substance
everywhere, almost like the spiritual equivalent
of a paper towel picking up dirt from a surface,
it reveals that La Llorona has definitely
made her mark on the house and the family.
Anna and the children assist Rafael in several
other rituals leaving the house looking very
similar to how Patricia’s looked when Anna
went to pay her that initial welfare check.
While doing this, Chris notices Rafael’s
cross, which he explains to be crafted from
the fire trees that surround the river where
La Llorona drowned her children.
– They say, the fire trees wept as La Llorona
drowned her children.
As the only witness to her sins, they hold
a special power over her.
– He also reveals the vial of La Llorona’s
black blood tears, which he collected from
Patricia’s house.
He mixes it with Holy water and refers to
it as “antivenom”.
La Llorona arrives later that night, viscous
and determined to find the children.
Anna and the kids believe they’re being
protected as they’re surrounded by candles,
huddled in the living room, under Rafael’s
direction, but La Llorona takes her by surprise
as she whales out a horrible sound that extinguishes
all of the lights.
(aforementioned horrible sound)
Anna and the kids are actually exactly where
La Llorona wants them.
It wouldn’t be a movie in the Conjurverse
if there weren’t some air yeeting and La
Llorona starts that here.
Anna is air yeeted out of the way and left
unconscious on the floor.
As the kids beg Rafael for help he does nothing
but instead slinks back into the shadows of
the house, leaving the kids unprotected and
completely susceptible to be air yeeted.
When Anna comes to, she gets up to try and
save her son, but she’s not going to make
it in time.
At just the last possible moment, Rafael sticks
a hand out and grabs Chris while throwing
his vial of his “antivenom” into La Llorona’s
face.
This has the desired effect and burns her
face so badly that she lets go of Chris and
Rafael is able to shove her out of the house
through the front door.
He slams it shut, and puts down another row
of seeds from the fire tree.
Explained another way, it was all a setup
to lock La Llorona out of the house, and to
her frustration, she fell for it.
Because the seeds are collected from the same
fire tree that the cross is made from, La
Llorona cross this barrier, as long as the
line is not broken.
And apparently she can’t use any of that
supernatural wind power to break them herself.
I don’t make the rules!
I guess Rafa overlooked the Garcia’s back
door though, because La Llorona promptly uses
her force to blow it up.
Anna, Chris and Rafael race back to seal it
shut but Rafael was not the only one playing
chess here, this was also just a clever distraction.
– Clever girl.
– She’s really just using the back door as
a diversion to trick Samantha into breaking
the seal.
La Llorona gets ahold of Misty, Samantha’s
beloved doll that she associates with her
deceased father.
She would not be the first or last evil entity
to manipulate a doll in the Conjurverse.
Misty is set outside, just barely out of Samantha’s
reach, so she’d have to reach out past the
seeds to get it.
It’s also fitting that she uses this doll
named Misty.
Mist is the gaseous form of water, and water
is La Llorona’s murder weapon.
Samantha takes the bait and is just barely
able to get Misty without breaking the line
of seeds, but Anna sees her at the last second
and yells at her to get away from the door,
causing her to get distracted and accidentally
drag the doll through the line of seeds, granting
La Llorona access to the house.
La Llorona immediately grabs Sam for one of
the most dramatic air yeeting sequences yet.
She takes her to the nearest body of water,
the backyard pool and holds her under.
Anna dives in and feverishly searches with
a flashlight.
Upon finding her at the bottom, La Llorona
attacks Anna, and during the scuffle, Anna
rips off La Llorona’s necklace; the same
necklace given to her by her boys that she
said she would wear forever.
This absolutely enrages La Llorona, it’s
the last connection she has to her own children.
But before she can retaliate, Rafael blesses
the water and mixes in salt, causing the pool
water to be turned into Holy water, which
drives La Llorona out.
Anna is able to rescue Samantha from drowning,
but just like Tomas, Samantha is now in a
trance just like what Patricia’s son Tomas
experienced shortly before his death.
Rafael and Anna realize that the only way
to keep Samantha from just walking outside
into La Llorona’s grasp again is that they
must keep her locked away, the same method
that Patricia was reprimanded for the night
of Anna’s visit.
So fittingly, Patricia would be La Llorona’s
last trump card to weaponize against Anna’s family.
Being a regular corporeal human, Patricia
has no problem simply walking over the fire
seed barrier to abduct Chris and Samantha.
– [Patricia] You took my babies from me.
She’ll give them back to me.
– [Zac] Patricia shoots Rafael in the shoulder and
breaks the line of seeds at the door, allowing
La Llorona to get inside.
It isn’t completely clear if Patricia entered
Anna’s house on her own volition, or if
it was under La Llorona’s direction, but
in either case, we know she was manipulated
by her belief that her children’s souls
could be freed if she offered the souls of
Anna’s children in their stead.
La Llorona, after powering her way through
everyone into the house, tosses Anna into
the basement stairway.
As she is thrown, she drops La Llorona’s
necklace, but Chris picks it up and keeps
it close.
At this point the trance on Samantha is broken
with no explanation as to why.
I would speculate that it could be tied to
the sunrise, a symbol of the passage of time
into the next day.
Again, this goes back to the idea that Patricia
brought up way back at the beginning: that
she only needed to keep her family safe a
little longer, and then the evil would potentially
move on.
The children run to the attic, but the Bawlin’
Broad finds and corners them.
As the final moments draw near and she walks
towards them, Chris uses his last
line of defense, La Llorona’s necklace.
This causes her anger to suddenly disappear.
Her face returns to the soft, kind features
from her natural life.
Different people are going to interpret this
in different ways, but I think in that
moment La Llorona saw Chris as one of her
own children, offering the necklace, and anger
and malice temporarily went away, allowing
her to take on the appearance of more of a
friendly ghost.
On the contrary, you could look at it as another
one of her tricks – her trying to get the
Garcia children to let their guard down.
The moment of pleasantness would be short
lived, however, as Samantha accidentally uncovers
a mirror, allowing La Llorona sees the reflection
of her true monstrous self, eyes covered in
black blood, and she immediately reverts to her
previous form.
This moment did buy Chris and Samantha just
enough time for Anna and Rafael to reach the
attic and protect them.
La Llorona turns her attention to Rafael,
because he poses the biggest threat with his
cross made from the fire tree seeds.
She vehemently throws him into a pile of boxes.
With all of the Garcia family together now,
she charges them, however, Rafael is just
able to kick his the cross across the room
to Anna who grabs it and promptly stabs La
Llorona through the chest.
(La Llorona screams as she decomposes)
And that would conclude the Garcia family’s
chapter with the malicious Central American
legend.
However!
This might not be the final chapter of her
story.
After Anna and the kids say goodbye to Rafael
later that morning, she looks back into a
puddle and sees something that alarms her
while we hear the sounds of children’s laughter.
(laughter)
Could this be the the return of La Llorona,
who was always associated with water, or does
the youthful laughter suggest that a new entity,
perhaps one of her victims has legendized
as a new threat, joining the likes of Bathsheba,
Malthus, Valak, and Isla among many other
evil beings in the Conjurverse.
There is a lot more to learn about these antagonists,
so check out that playlist on the left for
the low-down on the Conjurverse’s most horrifying
villains.
And remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for
new horrors every week, ring the deathbell
and select ALL notifications and I will see
you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.
– [Velma] Jinkies, that's impressive!